il a
et ce soir c'est les trompettes de la
renommée si beaucoup la wii c'est fou la
c triomphe absolu
je vais vous dire c'est ce nuage à dire
mais mais ça rembourse de plein de
moments de solitude quand on est juste
avec un stylo voilà
alors pierre ferret dans votre dernier
cd comme depuis quelques années vous
aborder des problèmes de sociétés assez
grave mais toujours avec votre langage
coloré et vous dénoncez dans ce disque
que les déviances sexuelles
les sectes le dopage dans le sport la
guerre la pollution la drogue le racisme
les marchands d'armes et dangers du du
tabac vous prépare finalement assez un
petit peu enfoncer des portes ouvertes
m'en suis sûr d'autres je ne suis pas le
seul à parler de ça on trouve un bouton
on écoute ça toute la journée
bon je pense que c'est par un prisme un
peu particulier qui est le mien qui est
un homme une vision de la chose
je pense qu'il n'est jamais superflu de
rappeler aux enfants que un dealer c'est
de la merde et dealer que c'est de la
merde un dealer c'est jamais inutile de
le dire même aux enfants et j'espère
qu'un jour ces chansons là seront
apprises dans les maternelles même celle
qui porte mon nom alors est-ce que c'est
pas difficile finalement de dénoncer les
malheurs du monde la misère du monde
quand on vit dans une maison de rêve
comme ça à nangis en seine-et-marne avec
vingt mille bouteilles de vin dans sa
cave est ce que le fait qu'il n'ya pas
un décalage de la seule chose qui aimons
bien ma richesse
mon bonheur celui d'avoir une maison
accueillante pour y accueillir sur tous
les amis et puis bon j'ai pas de laverie
automatique j'ai pas de près de 2
restaurants sur les champs elysées à
faire de la bouffe rapide ça m'intéresse
pas ce genre de d'argent là
m'intéressent pas
pour de ces malaises et tout vole en
éclats et savent pas archi psy quai
l'ado
m
quand j'ai l'impression qu'il ya deux
trois ans on a vu revenir georges
brassens d'un seul coup les français
sont rendus compte que brassens je parle
déjà évidemment sont rendus compte que
brassens était un chanteur de folk
français quoi et que c'était intéressant
et j'ai besoin d'eux est le suivant je
voyais le jour un journal comme
libération qui vous rend hommage sur une
demi-page serait pas été le cas il ya
cinq ou dix ans un je ne sais pas ce qui
leur arrive à tous
alors on va maintenant passer la
deuxième actu de pierre perret donc ça
c'est un dictionnaire et qui s'appelle
le parler des métiers et c'est édité
chez robert laffont
pour le prophète
alors on sent page 13 mille deux cent
dix entrées 145 profession alors ccni
sur l'argot ni sur les vieux métiers
c'est sur les métiers d'aujourd'hui ça
oui bien sûr tu aimes bien sûr c'est
tous les métiers d'aujourd'hui vers
lesquels j'ai envoyé des enquêteurs
principalement des linguistes qu'il
savait de quoi il parlait qui s'est fait
poser les bonnes questions parce que
c'est pas toujours évident et
principalement des femmes qui sont
allées un peu dans tous les coins de
l'hexagone pour questionner des gens qui
mettait des sardines en boîte qui
faisait de la viticulture qui était
cordonnier qui était flic qui étaient
tous to you pour approcher 250 p tit il
en faut beaucoup alors il se retrouve
même dans les commissariats ou des
églises ou des voix regain questionnant
des gens pour obtenir parfois
d'élocution assez assez cocasse
hallucinante où curieuse c'est vous qui
les ai payées on pourrait penser quand
même que c'est le boulot de l'académie
française d'envoyer des gens dans les
provinces pour recueillir les les
jargons suit le travail qui aurait été
certainement dans leur domaine et
c'était plutôt à eux de reculer ce
patrimoine comme moi parce que 28 qu'une
personne tout d'elle physique est bon
mais ça m'a fait un plaisir fou de
m'offrir ça même que je me suis offert
ça alors en 63 moi j'avais 14 ans quand
votre premier succès le tord boyaux et
est sorti et j'ai appris en préparant
cette interview qu'en fait c'était pas
complètement innocent parce que vous
êtes né dans un café restaurant vos
parents étaient bistrotiers et quand on
sait ça c'est explique assez bien votre
votre truculence votre humour votre
façon d'être
vos parents s'appelait maurice et
claudia perret et il avait le café du
pont à castelsarrasin à la sortie de la
ville entre l' usine d'aluminium et la
caserne et alors c était votre école de
la vie celle d'istres de l'otan oui
parce que autour d'un comptoir dans un
café et les clients refont vraiment le
monde et puis votre mère qui voulait
vous en voyez vous coucher qui vous
tirer par la manche ce soir il y
accorder
propos donné un peu scabreux j'ai vu ton
assez entendu rentrer se coucher
la phrase c'était pierrot à la cuisine à
14 ans conservatoire de toulouse 15 ans
conservatoire d'art dramatique 19 ans
1er prix de saxo et accessible de
comédie et puis débuts sur les planches
à vous commencez à vouloir jouer et là
il ya un libraire qui vous fait
découvrir la lecture qui vous passent
des classiques français c'est lui qui
vous a vraiment branché sur les mots oui
monsieur merveilleux qui a comblé les
lacunes qui étaient les miennes
parce que partir après un certificat
d'études et se trouvait confrontée au
texte de molière shakespeare ou courtes
les au musée j'étais très malheureux et
même un peu humide y est il faut bien le
dire parce que c'est très très humiliant
quand on sait pas on entre dans un monde
on comprend pas tout personnellement
j'étais moins qu'une sensibilité quand
même
et un jour ce monsieur je suis rentré
pour acheter un
un bouquin au rabais je crois que je
jouais les plaideurs le petit jean des
plaideurs racines et j'ai demandé en
bouquins bon marché et c'est la hat
andry il m'a vu il m'a dit bon ben là
venez et il m'a amené dans une caverne
d'ali baba qui l'avait hors de la
librairie à 100 mètres de là et c'était
des anciennes caves de 2,2 qui datait
d'aidé de deux trois ou quatre cents ans
et il y avait des trésors là dedans du
bouquin de théâtre de poésie du tout
mais du bouquin très ancien et la
laisser vous servir il m'a laissé me
servir et il m'a mis en main des
ouvrages que j'aurais jamais
lui tout seul ou monter à paris vous
êtes fan de brassens à l'époque et vous
allez voir dans sa loge vous lier
d'amitié avec avec brassens et c'est ça
sa compagne pub chaîne qui vous a dit de
chanter d'une certaine façon vous osiez
pas le faire donc j'ai dit mais je suis
pas chanteur
elle aimait georges non plus alors vous
êtes remarquer félicité à l'époque donc
par boris vian et jacques canetti grand
écran tonnes si l'on fût canetti
découvreur de talents aurait père eddie
barclay ou signe et là vous faites la
connaissance de simone mazen taryn qui
devient votre compagne après que vous
l'ayez rebaptisé rebecca quand même oui
c'est vrai simon et les mains on épouse
toujours la même c'est fou car en 40 ans
40 ans d'acharnement thérapeutique
mais
simons et plus tu m'épouser vos tenues
ce vote secrétaire votre votre attaché
de presse je ne fais rien de
d'importants je veux dire sans en
référer avec elle et l'oeil et l'oreille
les plus importants pour moi
pour sûr pour une chanson nouvelle c'est
c'est son oeil et son oreille
si jamais elle est là une réaction
mitigée sur une chanson un jeu peut être
malade pendant une semaine sans le dire
à personne mais je vais jouer à voir les
patates au fond du filet pour une
semaine là c'est sûr